>>Michael: I think social media, it
really directly helps the students see
that school is not this classroom.
School is the world, and so when
you have direct links to that world,
then they understand
the power of learning.
>>Pam: I got people that are walking
into Albemarle County virtually
and working with teachers, and as
Superintendent, I don't have this mote
around the school division anymore
that determines who gets to come or go,
and then I started realizing that what
people were doing was sharing resources,
they were asking questions, they
were engaging in interacting
around the work of learning.
>>Karen: This part will
be the Colosseum.
>>As a classroom teacher, I'm lucky
to know what other grade levels
are doing some of the time,
much less what are teachers
in other schools doing.
So what we do is connect
with Twitter a lot.
I think a lot of the ideas
that I come back and share
with kids, I saw on Twitter.
>>Pam: Social media catches on in
schools in the same way that it catches
on in the bigger world, that
it's kind of word of mouth.
So you may have a teacher that
does something in a faculty meeting
on how they use Twitter, and the next
thing you know that teacher is sitting
around with five or six other teachers
that're saying, "Hey, how do I get on?"
>>Michael: We formed a nice
little tight group with people
within Albemarle County
that use Twitter,
and so we pretty consistently
will Tweet each other directly
to see what the other person is doing.
So a hashtag that we use throughout
the district would be hashtag ACPS.
It's kind of a slow process at first.
You kind of send these Tweets out.
You're really sending Tweets
to no one because you have
like ten followers or something.
But then, you know, people
start to pay attention,
and luckily if you follow people
that follow you, that have a lot
of followers, they will
promote you to certain ways.
>>Pam: One day, I'm just, you
know, watching my Tweet feed,
and I notice this Twitter feed from
Michael Thornton, and it pops up,
and then he's got a picture of
his kids having built this tower.
>>Student: I think it's just the
ones that have come too close
to ripping that are the problem.
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Michael: So they're
given 20 sheets of paper.
They take that paper, they can
fold it how they want to use it,
but they can't use glue,
they can't use tape.
And the goal to see is how high you
can actually build the paper tower.
I Tweeted out the initial
pictures from it,
and just kind of explained what it was.
>>Pam: And then the next thing I know, I
see another teacher who's kind of taken
on the challenge, and
she's posted a picture
of her kids' tower with
them just beaming!
>>Michael: The response
was positive right away.
So I then said, "You know what?
I'll create a Google Doc that people
could actually then do the challenge
and then throw their
picture into the Google Doc."
>>Pam: Next thing you know,
we've got somebody up in Chicago,
we've got somebody in neighboring
Nelson County, they've built a tower.
You just start to see
these ideas that seed,
and then you've got connections
all over the place.
>>Michael: Hello!
Hey, welcome!
>>Beyond just the four walls that are in
this classroom, and with their teacher
or their parents, they can share
it with a classes in Chicago,
or classes in Ireland,
or across the world.
And that's really important
to them, because truly,
what they're doing, as we know, matters.
>>Pam: What if you don't
think about the boundaries
of your school district
as being a limiter.
What if you want your teachers, your
Principals, your Central Office staff,
even your kids to have opportunities to
cross-pollinate across the boundaries
of school districts, then all
of a sudden social media makes learning
come alive in incredibly powerful ways.